في السودان ليس من الضروري ان تتجه الى
الاطراف والحدود واماكن الحروب لتجد معالم
الفقر
بامكانك ان تشاهد كثيرا من مظاهر التردد
الوضع الاقتصادي وانعكاساته في العاصمه
الخرطوم
تنهار جدران المنازل وتنهار معها كثير من
الاحلام
فتتبدل الاعمال الى الام تصيب الاسر
والسبب نقص في الاموال والثمرات
هنا في بعض المناطق تزداد معاناه الحصول
على غذاء او ما يخفف المرض من دواء عائشه
خميس امراه مكافحه تعول سبعه من الابناء
والبنات تسعى لتوفير القليل في وضع
الاقتصادي المعقد كبير عندي سبع اطفال
عائشه مجرد ومثال لملايين المواطنين الذين
يحتاجون الى مساعدات عاجله
بحسب تقرير الامم المتحده الاخير في
ارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه وتراجع النشاط
الاقتصادي فضلا عن عدم الاستقرار السياسي
جعل الثلث سكان السودان يعانون من ضعف
لتوفير اساسيه الحياه
الانسانيه بقيمه مليار و700 مليون دولار
عدد الاحتياج زاد بمليون شخص عن العام
الماضي
المبلغ المخصص لمقابله احتياجات العام
المقبل يزيد كثيرا عما انفق خلال هذا
العام ولا ينحصر المجال فقط في توفير
الغذاء اينما كذلك في التعليم والصحه
وقطاعات اخرى
سوداني ستصل له مساعدات
انسانيه من الغذاء والماء والصحه والتعليم
من جديد
تحديات عديده تواجه الامم المتحده بينها
توفير مبلغ مليار و700 مليون دولار وكيفيه
الوصول الى ملايين المواطنين في ظل عدم
توفر قاعده بيانات خاصه بهم لن يعقوب
العربيه الخرطوم